for 300 years the lab her family has
cultivated their farm in South Africa's
Western Cape Province together with his
two sons cozy ljubka mainly grows corn
on his 2,500 hectare farm using
high-tech machinery he's invested a lot
and does not support the government's
proposed land reform and it is not a
Christian land can be poverty you first
must get the right people to do the job
they must be qualified people they must
be they must be skilled people to do the
job there's no problem I've got nothing
it's not a Calabasas it's a skilled
problem that we have with land reform
for more than 20 years South Africa's
government has tried to redistribute
land to Black's buying up to ten percent
of white owned farmland at market prices
but most black farmers don't succeed for
lack of experience the South African
Farmers Association is not totally
opposed to the reform but they say the
new law should not destroy South African
farms what we favor is a kind of a joint
venture partnership model and an
innovative financing model we there is
also financing that can encourage these
kind of partnerships between those
farmers and the workers who want to go
this route and who are able to do so
political pressure is mounting on the
government the leader of the opposition
party economic freedom fighters Julius
Malema is demanding the expropriation of
land from white farmers without
compensation
it's a popular idea among the black
majority
this would amount to a catastrophe for
white farmers it's very irresponsible we
think of what is likely if if to
advocate that because that will have a
very negative impact on the whole
economy if anybody would just start
taking forms without compensating the
current formers justly and without being
able to actually predict produce on
those wrongs many questions remain
unanswered much to the frustration of
farmers like cozy ljubka he'd like to
invest more in his farm but only if his
family can keep it in the long run